[Music]
hello bill my name is Danny Knoller
politically I tend to be conservative
and by faith I'm a Christian I believe
that anthropogenic global warming is
real and that the big bang theory and
evolution are perfectly valid theories
obviously this was made as with most
people in my demographic and I find that
conversations with my peers on these
topics usually devolve into arguments on
some other random subject entirely my
question for you is why these topics so
politically charged when they're matters
of science and not politics and how do I
engage in a meaningful conversation
thank you for answering Danny Danny
Danny you've touched on a subject that I
find fascinating and you've spent a lot
of time on myself so I'm really glad you
asked this but when it comes to
anthropogenic global climate change
human caused global climate change its
politicized because of the fossil fuel
industry and I spend a lot of time with
this I've asked myself as a native of
the United States
now the engineering degree in the United
States I got my license and I practiced
and I'm an engineer in the United States
why is the United States not the world
leader in addressing climate change why
isn't the United States the world leader
in renewable energies better water
purification or desalinization
techniques better ways to provide the
Internet to everyone on earth why isn't
the u.s. leading and I am satisfied it's
because of the success of the denial
community or the deniers they have
managed to introduce the idea that
scientific uncertainty plus or minus two
percent about whatever it might be is
the same as plus or minus on a percent
as doubt about the whole thing and
that's wrong so what to do about it what
I always remind myself and the example I
I learned from or claimed I learned from
was what we traditionally call skeptical
thought or a skeptical point of view or
critical thinking when you tell somebody
who reads her or his horoscope every day
that horoscopes are false that there is
no scientific evidence people have tried
over and over to validate horoscopes and
there is no connection between is
written on those what is written on
those pages and what happens in
your life none and this even the whole
idea of the full moon that there are
more hospital visits on a full moon is
false it statistic you can show it it's
not complicated there are no more
hospital visits on a full moon than
other times okay the first time someone
you're having a conversation with here's
these things he or she is troubled and
reacts might push you away but what you
do is in my opinion is you chip away at
it the first time the person hears this
that the fossil fuel industry
cherry-picks data the fossil fuel
industry has thrown a lot of money at
conservative members of US Congress in
order to support their political
campaigns if they will support for
example no changes in the way coal is
mined for example the first time they
hear it they reject it
but if you just chip away at it after a
while I think you can convince people
bring them around to your point of view
and the other thing just important I
think will help focus your discussions
is the word theory now the word theory
is something we is a word we throw
around all the time I have a theory it's
raining outside haha but in science a
theory is a special thing and it's not
complicated it means you can make a
prediction if you have a theory of
evolution you can make predictions about
living things in nature based on your
theory you can make predictions about
about climate change based on measuring
atmospheric gases and making computer
models that jive or work together well
with evidence in geology or in the
ancient rocks if you have a theory of
time we were talking recently about
relativity you can make predictions
based on the theory and and the
predictions will be true so when you are
having these discussions with people
to see what it is see if they have a way
with their point of view that enables
them to make predictions so talking some
more about me as you may know I bet to
renowned or notorious climate change
deniers I bet them each $20,000 and
neither of them will take the bet I was
willing to put 40,000 bucks of my own
money on the table that 2016 will be
among the top 10 hottest years ever
recorded the decade 2010 2020 will be
the hottest decade ever recorded and
neither one of these guys
neither Marc Morano Joe Bastardi would
take those bets because they know in my
opinion they know better and so their
beliefs or what they claim are more
accurately but they claim their beliefs
are about the Earth's climate system
really don't make any predictions about
it and so just ask your friends how they
feel about making a prediction based on
their theories and to give you an
example that is just kind of fun but
annoying there is a species of mosquito
now and the London Underground in the
subways of London that generally cannot
mate with mosquitoes at the surface they
live these mosquitoes molest us live in
the underground in the subway tubes
because there's so much to eat there
that is to say you and me and apparently
they really started making this
migration late in the 1800s but they got
very thin mosquitoes got very successful
during World War two when these subway
stations were used as bomb shelters and
their people be down there at night and
these insects have lived down there
without the need to go upstairs for
decades and so they're now genetically
divergent enough from their ancestors
that they can't mate with them
successfully and evolution can make
predictions like that other theories
about a deity that waived his or her
hand
created all these insects or other
species cannot make any such predictions
they would have made no such prediction
about an emergent species in the London
subway and so on and so on so see if you
can focus your discussions with your
friends on predictions and and the place
to start don't to get in a big thing
about it but that's what a theory is in
science is it makes predictions good
luck keep us posted let us know how it
comes out thanks for calling thanks for
a video recording carry on
[Music]